immigration matters a long way from the
Kent Coast
with people you know illegally you know
illegal coming over in marginal Northern
seats like dewsbury we need immigration
for some sort of sectors in our
community yeah but the big family
members are over and just getting bigger
and bigger and bigger places that will
become an election Battleground where
people are watching the government's
bold plan to stop the boats when will
the new detention centers be open for
business
well we already have a detention
we are we are on the port we are rolling
out new detention spaces to support when
the detention pressures I'm not going to
give precise dates because uh we will
have uh you know we've got uh logistical
uh challenges that were always
overcoming Logistics are one thing but
is this bill even legal look at this I'm
unable to make a statement that in my
view this bill is compatible with the
European convention on human rights
that's very unusual do you think this is
going to end up in court it will
certainly end up in the courts because
individuals will challenge what the
government does this bill obviously will
take a few months to go through
Parliament and perhaps the government
hopes that this will be in force by the
summer then there will be challenges and
they could take months even years to go
through the court the government hopes
that simply publishing this bill and
talking tough will begin to deserve
migrants from coming here will you break
the law to stop the boat prime minister
May well relish a battle in the courts
and with the labor party his position
against measures to deport foreign
criminals Mr Speaker and he even argued
against deportation flights well and we
know why because on this matter he
talked about his legal background he's
just another Lefty lawyer standing in
our way
all they offer is the same old gimmicks
and empty promises I don't agree with
the home sector on very much but when
she says that the Tories are all talk
and no action she's spot on isn't she
the government's weak spot is a
workability of this plan but immigration
policy is election material and they
sense a weakness in labor behind the
scenes number 10 are pretty pleased with
how the last few days have gone
he's a PM Keen to be seen in control
earlier marking International women's
day as he tries to tackle immigration
in the end success maybe more about the
politics than the policy Ali forsku's
Sky News Westminster